[Music]
it's a simple concept M club we bleed so
you don't have
to when you join up we have to be able
to say what it is that you can't say
otherwise we're stealing from
you so mug Club is exactly what has
allowed us all of us to remain
completely independent since 2016 before
that online Revenue was generated by ads
YouTube Facebook they kept telling us
what kind of content we were permitted
to post what kind of creators they would
be happy to work with and exactly what
kind of people what kind of
conservatives would be put in the
corner we're growing M Club we're
growing M Club stomach at then I can't
stomach it now and no one here can and
because of mug Club because of you we
don't have
to when I say it's you but it's not just
a buzzword it's precisely because of of
you m club that these things are now
even permissible on these big Tech
platforms when an entity comprised of
nothing more than all of you all of you
you are who we serve you are to whom we
are beholding and you're the driver of
billions of views the people who want to
silence you who want to dictate what you
hear who hate everything you stand for
well guess what they can't deplatform us
all we didn't start this fight we don't
want it but if you want a fight you
better believe you'' got one Nick theal
Alex Jones B Club on cover Rumble is our
heart so now as a full-fledged Network
mug Club is bigger than them and that's
why all of us here are genuinely free
you mug Club are the reason that they
are scared H coming with
me we can keep fighting because of
mug
remember none of this is possible
without you join the fight and sign up
for mug club today at lwith c.com
mugclub for $89 annually join the fight
at Lou withth credit.com mugclub
[Music]
[Applause]
today don't
Str that's what I
[Music]
know I'm not even sipping you just made
my list tool man as we were coming into
the show what was that adjustment my
balls were all Bunch stuff
a right before he stands up and he goes
he had this look of abject
Panic like he realized oh no we're about
to go live I have to do
this sorry just glad you didn't leave
the camera on yourself thank goodness
you work here we had 10 seconds we have
a pro ball policy and breast
now glad to be with you
uh hey you know what Howard Howard Stern
call us horrible people which we'll be
talking about today so this is the
rundown you have Howard Stern now he's
decided that you know he wants to uh use
Lauren bobert to Virtue signal that's
correct Howard Stern is virtue signaling
now at the same time we have Russell
Brand who has now been demonetized on
YouTube for allegations that are decades
old and have yet to be proven uh he has
yet to be charged but YouTube has
decided that that may harm their current
viewers we'll get into the UAW strike
how that affects you exactly a lot of
you may not realize this but your
problem isn't necessarily with the UW
it's with um the fact that they're who
is the UAW striking against you the
taxpayer because these auto
manufacturers cease to exist if not for
your NeverEnding supply of bailout funds
and we have a guest Owen Shroyer you
guys know him over there of course Alex
Jones at uh madmax world. I almost said
the wrong word um and he has just been
um I think he's been he's been charged I
believe he was sentenced for 60 days got
to serve 60 days for simply being there
yes on January 6 have him on the show
and look we're able to talk about this
we're able to talk about Russell Brand
being demonetized we're able to stand in
the pocket for we're able to have the
the uh the the Owen I was about to say
the UAW the Owen Shroyer on the owy
we're able to have him on uh regardless
of YouTube rules because of mugclub
that's it this is this is we're back on
YouTube today so please hit the like
button um I would even say if you're
watching on Rumble right now just just
switch over to YouTube really quick to
hit like and and help with that
algorithm because they want you to
believe that we are dead we were
suspended we probably be suspended again
and then go back to rumble and then go
back to back over to rumble what are you
doing and if at any point during today's
show if you're new here you're watching
on YouTube and you see
this that means that uh it's available
on Rumble right there's a slight delay
you said something yeah there's a few
second delay so we can dump it on
YouTube and go we're not going to
self-censor that's the best that we have
all right I think we've gotten all of
that out of the way uh let me ask you
this how many of you still believe that
it's better to buy American now with the
UW strike you should be American by Amer
well hold on a second it's still cheap
Chinese crap that's assembled in America
by American
Communists so I'd rather just go with
the cheaper Communists at that point how
about you just be good yeah be American
by the best all right there he is uh
number two CEO you were feeling a little
bit out of source yesterday I was
feeling weird yesterday I don't know why
I was just tired or I I don't know yeah
we'll see big big day so big day
yesterday yeah I'm good today how are
you I'm fine I had to rub some uh Tiger
Bomb on my neck and I I broke my own la
and went to the restroom after without
the without Triple washing my hands
how's that that's why I have no sympathy
for Tim who had to Tool manual had to
make the adjustment you think I don't
want to Tiger nice tool man if you
Google Icy Hot o the first thing that
shows up is Icy Hot on balls that's
what's suggested don't do it don't do or
eyes you guys can comment below if
that's ever happened to you Icy Hot come
on guys you all know that's happened and
in third chair yeah he puts a smile on
her face when you hear this you know it
is Thursday October 19th you will be
Summit City comedy club in fort way
Indiana sorry I has to go to Indiana
Josh firestein how are you sir good good
I uh I'm doing good I by the way I'm not
supporting the Auto industry I'm going
to travel by balloon only really yeah
I'm changing my it's eco-friendly you
get in the hot air balloon it just float
on down but I saw that film with the guy
was it the Arona Nots whatever it is
with the guy from he played Steven
Hawking the big lips yeah yeah yeah that
guy would love to see Steven Hawkin in a
balloon yeah just with the controls this
was a bad idea oh oh this was too
high he's dead he puts the in
the
basket cuz a hot air balloon is a basket
that you write in it's pretty it would
have landed more softly said it puts the
in the basket I'm not good at
impression see it softens the blow um
for the word but it's a fun word
all right you're already having notes
being passed your is there something I
need it said check yes or no would you
please stay out of it what did you check
what did you check or what is this about
the UN assembly I checked no is this
about the UN assembly no well I I so I
passed a note to our team I I saw Biden
speaking and I'm like I don't care that
he's speaking I said be on the lookout
for Biden gffs at the UN speech so all
right really quickly let's just see what
he's saying Reflection Point in world
history with the eyes of the world upon
all of you all of
us as president of the United States I
understand the duty my country has duty
to lead in this critical moment stop it
to work with countries in every region
linking them common cause to join
together with Partners who share a
common vision of the future of the world
well look I will say this no one shares
the progressive left's vision of the
world we've talked about this before you
know I've said there are a couple of
times where I've looked back now and
said hey maybe maybe we're the bad guys
and I don't mean America I don't mean
the founding fathers I don't mean the
red white and blue what it stands for
but the vision for example of puberty
blockers of sex changes for kids of
never running bailouts for uh not only
uh Union companies of course like the
the the auto Manu but
also did everyone just decide to cough
that was nine
people um you're talking about of fiser
madna of forced vaccination mandates of
locking ourselves down of of control of
every single one of your private
decisions of of silencing people for
wrong think who shares that this is the
first time where actually I don't really
know if the vision that former Vice
President Biden is I don't know if
that's something we want to export yeah
genuinely there used to be a point in
time where even if you were a
non-interventionist you at least had
some semblance of the idea that America
was trying to at the very least bring
maybe their brand of Freedom which was
rejected by these countries for example
in the Middle East or across uh across a
lot of Asia but we're not even really
trying to export Freedom now our vision
is hey do what we do and and that's
taking children away from parents and
that's uh not having transparent honest
elections and that's having our
government step on big Tech to ensure
that people with different points of you
are no longer allowed there I don't
really I mean you can comment it's the
first time where I feel really
conflicted that if I were in I don't
know if I were in a country somewhere in
Eastern Europe and I saw what one point
at one point in time would be that that
Cavalry coming over that Hill America I
I like you know what we're good stay
back I don't know that it's something
that the rest of the world wants to be
on board with anymore and I don't know
that it's something I want to be on
board with anymore the country yes it's
founding yes you yes but this guy I
don't want anything that he's selling to
be exported to other I think the world
will be a worse place if his vision in
the DNC and Camala Harris's vision and
Elizabeth Warren's vision and Hillary
Clinton's vision and Gavin Newsome's
vision and Gretchen whitmer's Vision
again think of what they would do
completely unfettered think of what the
world would look like if Gretchen
Whitmer if Gavin new were in charge of
the UN yeah that's a bad bad place yeah
it's an incredibly Fair Point to make
too we want the country that we grew up
with not the country that we have right
now run by these guys it's the reverse
Michael Obama where you know he said
that for the first time when my husband
was elected
I was proud of I felt proud of my
country for the first time I will say
this as an American um I'm not ashamed
to be American but I am ashamed of what
we are exporting to the world a part of
me is embarrassed by it for the first
time you can comment below or hit like
if you're on YouTube and you feel that I
don't think that makes you any less of a
patriot I think it makes you a patriot
to what this country is supposed to
actually be all right if they say
anything else at the UN stupid but they
will Cas point right here a Dallas
Church think of the you when you think
of Dallas you probably think of the show
The Fountain but you probably think of
you probably think of America right you
probably think patriotism maybe some
cowboy hats and by the way anyone who
wears a cowboy hat in Texas who's not an
actual Rancher you're a dick no you're
not I saw a bunch of them at Globe Life
oh really stop it all of you so fake new
Balan isn't a cowboy hat shut up you
want to be comfortable and have a ston
yeah no actually this is a Yellowstone
branded hat yeah that's true authentic I
don't like those cowboys you see my
flirt jeans so hey that's me a Dallas
church
now uh has been giving an unorthodox
blessing to drag queens in the pews
about family values the first thing that
comes to my head is focus on the family
some of the ways in which those Family
Values if you will have been hijacked by
the religious be better off being
religious
wrong to people
[Music]
ofice drag queens up there I think there
were about 40 of
them just zombies not a
[Music]
joke right M at least they're hanging
God's promise to
Noah
exactly hey hold on a second how does
that come up how does that come up as
far as look I you you can actually be a
liberal and say hey you know what I'm
I'm Episcopalian which basically means
you're nothing at this point but you can
say all right and so they allow you know
whatever samex marriage but how does
that how is that relevant in any way to
a position of leadership in the church
nowhere else are like hey could you uh
hey Mr Morgan you're married could you
come up and uh tell tell uh tell of
course our our congregation what
position you
prefer I understand I understand I
[Music]
understand relevancy and this is the
failure of the church need to be other
churches call it's not it could not be
less relevant to the word of the Lord
aside from that you know the whole
Abomination thing and then by the way it
is reiterated in Romans it it's I get
scripture drag queens may not be gay
right their gender queer you know some
of them just like kids that was a pride
flag in the background so let me just
say this you're wrong on so many things
but you said radical inclusivity you
know who was not radically inclusive
Jesus I am the way the truth and the
life is a very exclusive statement it
brings it down to one right he is the
only you can't be a church I even had to
ask the question I talked to our team
about this I was like is this a
Christian church or is this just like
one of those churches that says they're
a church that doesn't really believe
anything no no it's actually a Christian
Church that's doing this and if you're
trying to do Outreach to the gay
community I understand that I actually
worked with some Churches in Dallas who
did that back when I was doing Ministry
School to try to help Outreach and some
guys that had come out of being
homosexual and actually were now
straight and married and had wife and
kids and were trying to do Outreach they
it work fine that's fine but that's not
what this is this is basically saying
everything's okay doesn't matter what
God's word says it matters how you feel
and being inclusive and tearing down
systems of this and the religious right
what in the hell are you talking about
it's not a far Fringe policy to say that
God says life is found here and it's not
found here you can't go but God's wrong
it can also be found there because Love
Is Love he's one of those extremist who
doesn't think that drag queen should be
at church up in front of children what a
dork let's call have some fun already
let's call the Anti-Defamation League
and get him listed as an
extremist that's a real Church though
for sure because you could tell cuz the
Reverend had a scarf of Many Colors yes
he did ah like Joseph that's right yeah
the Technicolor Dream Coat or or Desmond
Tutu which is actually just a Str it's
just a stage name for burles yeah he
wears a scarf and the nipple tassels
puts a lot of work in I'll give him
credit for the effort it's Evil all
right Mommy why are there clowns in
church that's what you would hear from
exactly yes yes hey Mom why are there a
bunch of people who are wearing the
colors that all animals show in nature
to warn for fear Venom or
danger on their face bright colors and
large scary
teeth nothing about this is is is is
Church of it's not that look you want to
dress up and go into a gay bar nobody
cares remember was you're in a church
we're not even talking about now on the
street in a gay pride parade you're in a
church you're a church I don't want to
wear a polo either but I'm dressing up
for the part do it no you you go to Old
Navy and you grab yourself some khaki
cargos if you have to you suck it up for
a little bit yes and let us know guys
we're thinking about going down to some
of these churches that are pushing
agendas like this and actually having
some conversations let me know if you
guys want us to go and do remember when
they used to say it was a conspiracy
that there was a gay agenda now they
actually have it outlined with lgbtq
plus and they have it on the church
agenda literally inws agenda that was
their entire we praise and worship we'll
pass the offering feel free to uh put in
your fake and then we will uh
continue with
then we'll break for Sunday school let
us know if you need the extra large
plate to be passed around yeah yeah then
they they throw in condoms instead of
money can you imagine I mean Jesus threw
tables he threw tables at the temple
because they were selling stuff I know
this was the service what do you think
what do you think Jesus Christ would
have done just to get rid of by the way
this this isn't a Pious thing what do
you think Jesus Christ would have done
if they didn't tell them you know hey
they're selling some stuff at the temple
they're selling their wees but he said
yeah there are drag queens teaching
children like what what's what is a drag
queen it's a man who dresses up like a
woman and puts his sexual degeneracy on
display for all to see but now uh he
also teaches Sunday school so uh you
should really hear his rendition of
Jonah and the whale it's a show tune
it's a show tune and it involves some
harassment I bet Jesus would have been
like have you heard of uh these cities
Sodom and gomorra ex dad had beef with
yeah yeah telepathically turn them into
salt from where he stands all right so
uh Howard Stern you guys are passing so
many notes it's it's one note this is
five notes yesterday you were all on
your notepad I'm going to write a not do
I need to know the note no okay I'll
write a note for you you write a note
I'll write we're left out of the notes I
know it's just it's too many notes yeah
all right Howard
Stern just noticing everything today he
is you're
what people are watching fine to all
right so we have the church now the
church is catering to degenerates and
now Howard Stern is virtue signaling to
the left oh jeez Howard Stern yeah about
about sexual Purity basically so yeah
the guy who had strippers play the
harmonica with their vagina oh the guy
from the yeah wow possible so now he
decided to give his take on
representative Lauren bobert's recent
Behavior at and look I'm not going to
get into this with there's a boob grab
and whatever I just don't think people
will vote for Lauren bobbert or they
won't uh but the fact that Howard Stern
now who is the definition of shock jock
has decided that he is morally Superior
to Lauren bobbert um tells you the
strange state of our times Lauren
bobbert is a disgrace to this country
not because the vi you are 100% right
forget the politics she's in a titty
dress if you saw the video she's in a
titty dress she's with some dude looks
like she's you know obviously vaping but
also looks like she might be penis
during Beetle Juice I've seen porn stars
wear more and this dude that she's with
is playing with her titties during it
they're having a party and I mean take
away the
politics she's fun now there's so much
irony there's so much irony here because
you know here I can't believe she would
behave this way at Beetlejuice how about
the fact that you had a uh a
black named Beetle juu compete in
celebrity boxing and cause a reparable
brain damage and uh later on you know he
died you took advantage of a special
which by the way I get it it was funny
at that point he was a willing
participant you guys used to prank
Callum you guys used to torture a guy
named Beetlejuice
yeah and this is where just just just
for for context you know Stern again I
don't look if you're if you were a
consistent virtue signaling like a pearl
clutcher where everything was offensive
okay like Tipper Gore fine at least it's
you're consistently unfun but for Howard
Stern now he's going after people who
are unvaccinated he's gone after Joe
Rogan now he's going after
representative lord I can't believe this
behavior is reprehensible if you don't
remember and if you have children they
shouldn't be watching keep in mind this
is how Howard Stern became famous go
ahead let's get the flush going get our
head way in there get in there here yeah
I blow the bubbles I want to hear the
water it's it's kind of in the like the
little hole right now but if you when
you flush it it comes forward okay put
your head down more keep going more okay
that's good ready she should I flush
away flush here he goes
I am so going to win this I really want
I mean you got a perfect body thank you
not you KC I mean thank
you all
[Music]
right now look this is how the guy be
it's fine he's a shock Che that's his
thing F just be consistent about it and
my issues The Comedians and the
Entertainer now are going I can't
believe I can't believe that someone CED
a feel in a dark the the you can say
it's different because I'm an
Entertainer and this person is a
representative that's a valid but that's
not what you just he just said I just
can't I can't believe that behavior well
of course you can because you've done
far worst in a brightly brightly lit far
worst brightly lit studio for everybody
to see now I look I don't understand the
clothing thing I can't believe she was
wearing a boob dress and I'm like she
she had a dress on I've seen strippers
wear more no you haven't not a single
stripper ever has worn more than that
when they're doing you know the
stripping the thing that you just named
them after of course they Clos during
the day you but she was in a
theater at night Lorena bobbert needs to
make better decisions I'm going to say
that you're confusing Lauren bobbert and
Lorena bobbit sorry
Lauren that is a big she touched a Wier
she didn't throw it out a car window we
don't know what happened after that
we'll we'll have to see she needs to
make better decisions but look if
somebody's got night vision zooming in
on her with a security camera fine
there's going to be some times where
these things happen I'm not saying it's
okay but certainly Howard Stern can't
stand and
go can't believe that happened right he
turned into a yes huge dude
huge owie yeah it's remarkable
yeah and I'm not by the way I used to
like some of the stuff the funny bits I
didn't you know strippers playing the
Harmon or strippers like you know where
you're putting into their nether regions
that's that was just hack stuff but they
had some funny people on the show he did
some funny bits the problem is with
these people making their bones and then
pulling the ladder up behind them you
see it with Amy Schumer you see it with
these other comedians out there who
decide that you know what I'm not going
to say those those things anymore at
least Lampanelli was another one I don't
to be the queen of me I only want to be
an uplifting lgbtq plus Community well
guess what there are still other people
out there who share the sense of humor
of half of the country you know the
people who made you famous that's the
issue yeah is is is the now now that
you're in a multi well not multi-million
I think his house is 20s something
million doar his estate this guy locked
himself down during Co into his house he
was terrified from his own family
members he would quarantine himself this
is a man who lives in fear this is what
happens when you have absolutely no
moral compass whatsoever you have no no
filter through which you you view the
world so you go ah yeah yeah playing uh
you know playing putt putt into a
stripper uh into a stripper's butt no
that's fine oh wait a second people
getting a little handsy in a dark
theater I can every teenager by the way
they do that they make out in the
theater for K I'm not saying that this
is what you want with your
representatives but like I've said here
that's what we have mck unless you're a
murderer rapist or pickpocket I don't
really care if you do your job well I'm
going to judge people by their by their
principles yes by their actions but I'm
not going to judge them by an outof
context misde no one's life can stand up
to that scrutiny you have to look at the
body of work for crying out loud I'm
neutral on Lauren Lauren bobbert I'm
just not going to take part in that so
anything else I think I think that makes
sense yeah make better decisions and I
don't know what Dr I don't know what
change in Howard Stern sorry I know I
know what Chang he's he he got in
trouble he wasn't getting any viewers
this guy he's trying to come out and get
these gen xers and and he's doing what
the what they say they're not doing say
it doesn't exist it's the agenda he's
following the agenda he's following his
grip the putt putt in the butt butt
that's his idea that is his idea or
somebody they came up with that actually
yours is a better name pretty good
certainly hope he never got a hole in
one
on bring in some of those drag queens
from the from the from the church they
could be the clown
mouth give me a driver I don't know what
has fully changed with how look you are
I'm not a mind reader but we do have a
actually we do have a mind reader in the
office you know we're pretty tight with
the the X-Men and um you know Charles
Xavier the secondary characters well
Charles Xavier you know a big fan uh but
he's he's a busy guy he's expensive so
we do have actually we have though
managed to hire on trial basis um his
telekinetic brother if that's a his his
his brother Chad Xavier
[Music]
[Applause]
M I'm sensing a
problem yeah the uh drivers on this
piece see one update I only work on
[Music]
iOS oh we'll check back in with so by
the way it's a live show Monday through
Friday 10: a.m. eastern and uh the like
button stop it don't laugh at him I
would laugh at Tim Tim was so annoyed
Tim kind of a jerk actually he's so
useless hey guys come on this is
Howard's turn let's not be so come on
dude
easy are you trying to mind no I'm just
going through the the the different ways
in which we can already get in trouble
for today's show and it's a lot uh oh
was it the hot air balloon thing no no
no that doesn't but but it probably
didn't help as a lead in two chit Xavier
because they're going to say it's a
theme and you know what I own it hey hey
Howard Stern you can can be upset if you
want uh and uh we're going to have Owen
Shroyer on a little bit later on if he
still you know wants to
so you no one ditches us you know it's
like oh crap we we talked about this
yesterday but now there's been a
development uh Russell Brand of course
there have been women who've come
forward with these uh allegations of
sexual assault and again maybe there's
truth there's some truth to it maybe
there isn't we don't know but we're
supposed to live in a in a society where
you're innocent until proven guilty um
and these are also decades old
allegations he has not been convicted of
a crime he certainly hasn't been
sentenced and uh he had his tour
unfortunately canceled and now YouTube
has decided to demonetize Russell Brand
and this is why I say that appeasing
crocodiles is feudal they've demonetized
Russell Brand uh for something that has
nothing to do with his YouTube channel
YouTube say they've suspended the
monetization of Russell Brand's online
Channel it comes as the Mets say they've
received a report of an alleged sexual
assault in London in
so it was very hard to understand her
but here's
a basically he's on trial but he's not
on trial listen listen this is serious
he committed a rape he's a rapers we
can't have YouTubers going around raping
people take his money next thing you
know will be raping on Twitter I'm sorry
a
R it on
Facebook
Instagram Tik Tok it'll just be a
Cavalcade of rapist all over your screen
the algorithm it'll just be about who's
raping
who Ian I know I'm safe it doesn't aict
me that's how you know I don't have a
dog in this fight no one's raping
me and in other
news the economy down yeah and Haas
prices are
up other news no one thinks about
Scotland until they see this
video or if they smell hot
cabbage oh God all right all right all
right get it out of your system wait
wait this this just in Scotland's
national instrument has been rated worst
of all time no no yeah worst of all time
apparently it's just noise you can't
even hit a
note which by the way ironically it
doesn't set the mood which protects you
from rape don't worry I have one here y
oh yeah there you go that's why you have
a rape problem you start pay you play
enough Berry weight someone's getting
raped ain't no all I'm saying ain't n
ever getting raped with a bag
[Laughter]
pipe that'd be 50 shads of music I
don't know I got bag piped once you got
bag piped well that was I was hit with a
bag pipe I don't know what happened I
forgot after that Amnesia they see my
ass was s for week I think it was
re so anyway a YouTube spokesperson who
speaks English properly stated if a
Creator's off platform Behavior harms
our users employees or ecosystem we take
action so here's the thing how does this
how do allegations against Russell bran
from decades ago that have yet to be
proven now some people might try and
rewind this let's say let's say in some
Universe where Russell Brand is actually
guilty and there's actually hard
evidence that could very well still be a
possibility it doesn't change the fact
that right now at this moment in time at
9:41 Central on what's the date
September 19th on September 19th 2023
there have been no
criminal convictions sentencing nothing
no evidence has actually been presented
as far as we know at this moment in time
and that merely an article a smear
campaign is reason enough to demonetize
Russell Brand on YouTube and by the way
imagine if he' signed a contract with
one of the big conservative networks who
would punish him 25% this is the problem
too when conservatives appease these
people it doesn't matter what you do
someone can come out make an accusation
and you will be banned or removed or
demonetized from YouTube anyway that's
why mug Club is a thing I know I look
I'm just letting you know that's why we
have Nick depal there's no way that guy
was ever going to be allowed to be
monetized on YouTube Hodge twins Alex
Jones of course he's banned from YouTube
you can sign up led.com or don't but we
had to create this because we knew that
this was happening and too many
conservatives have played ball let me
ask how many people are going to stand
in the pocket for Russell BR not many
yeah this was what three days so I guess
Russell released his video on Friday so
he he basically led the story right so
Friday to yesterday yeah really YouTube
you've had enough time to do your due
diligence on that even if you were
saying that you looked into these
matters and thought it was severe enough
which is complete crap anyway no
convictions is not maybe innocent it is
100% absolutely innocent until proven
guilty 100% you can't start treating
somebody as guilty the minute an
accusation well not only that but the
problem is now YouTube is this is the
court of public opinion it's not just
the court of public opinion where people
are are uh just raking you over the cold
right running your name through the mud
you now actually have Financial
repercussions with no proof whatsoever
right there are a lot of people who make
their living on YouTube thank God we
don't by viewers Like You by the way
what was that a lot of felons a lot of
convicted felons do yeah a lot of
convicted felons do as well which fine
yeah someone who's not convicted though
Russell Brand there are consequences
that have nothing to do with actual
YouTube by the way we we weren't allowed
to be on YouTube Today's theme is
Shakedown that's what this this is a
Shakedown yeah we were banned from
YouTube right the Vox head apocalypse
for those of you who are new sorry they
created the borderline content rule
because of yours truly I didn't mean for
that to happen it was a goof but then we
had the socialism is for figs shirt yeah
and YouTube said which we love we sell
it the live shows only because YouTube
said if you have that in a merch shop
online you will not be allowed on
YouTube you will not be allowed to have
a shirt that is basically a pun because
we have deemed it too offensive even
though it is not on YouTube stupid what
is it like a big fig uh it's a it's ch
of a like this instead of a fist yeah
I've seen like what's the Fig problem
what's what's the problem socialism is
for figs is the you know socialism is
for figs are they in the big fig Market
yeah they're not really big they must be
date people ah works it doesn't make any
sense at all though right so it's not
just YouTube doing this I think his
somebody somebody had mentioned and we
can confirm this like stuff had been
pulled off of Netflix he had canceled a
lot of his shows I think his manager may
have even dropped him at this point like
everybody rushes for the exit because
nobody has the balls to sit there and
say I'm sorry he's innocent right now
I'm sorry this guy his life doesn't stop
because somebody makes a claim like we
can't live in a world like that it does
not it cannot work and people on the
left will say oh cancel culture people
just say you know what they just want to
be able to say whatever it's not cancel
culture it's accountability culture okay
where's the account accountability for
people making accusations and destroying
lives where's the accountability for
those people where's the accountability
for Christine blazy for let's be honest
about it where is we want accountability
culture it needs to go both ways oh
that's right sorry we're talking about
me too or even just sexual harassment in
the workplace it it goes one way what
about one way there's never
accountability for the women who make
false accusations and in this case you
have Russell Bren thank God he's on
Rumble you can go over there watch him
support him right we're here on Rumble
of course it's partnership we couldn't
be happier with with mug Club but what
if he wasn't boom living just just
turned off wars were fought over less
wars were fought over resources wars
were fought over the ability to feed
your family that's really if you think
when you think Wars used to be for land
or then at one point wars were over oil
why do you think that was significant it
allowed you to make a living and feed
your family and now you lose all of your
outlets for something that may have zero
credibility
whatsoever that would provide for your
family YouTube Revenue boom Gone live
shows boom gone think about wars were
fought for Less when people like you're
an extreme what do you think if you're
not willing to fight to feed your family
then what is worth it that's what all
wars were fought over and we we' we've
just glossed over it because we think of
it as a digital space Oh well you know
what you're not entitled to well hold on
a second if this is the only place that
people can make a living through this
method as well as live performances and
all of that gets taken away yeah you
can't just go and create your own
YouTube and then go and create your own
how many theaters 30 theaters for a tour
no you get shut out and that's why we've
been building this infrastructure for a
long time gay William he has
relationships with all of the theaters
where doesn't matter what you do hey
Russell If you're looking for someone
else who can gay William he's a Cuban by
the way just be on guard he hates Puerto
Ricans he's a little bit homophobic and
he's super gay just so you know but he
can help you out there it's weird
homophobic and gay at the same time it's
strange yeah well you know anything that
uh that he needs at this point in time
you know we can provide we about to say
oh and something else too this is
something else that a lot of people
don't know now this we haven't been able
to corroborate this yeah but we are able
to verify it through what's happened
here at Mud Club behind the scenes so
one woman says that she was contacted uh
specifically to Dish on brand but that
her story was not used I was contacted
in June by a journalist uh regarding a
video I made uh about a certain
celebrity and a weekend that we shared
together the video is kind of viral uh
it's on my page somewhere if you want to
go see it and that certain somebody was
as most of you will be aware Mr brand
they weren't going to use my story
because it didn't fit the narrative for
the documentary because he wasn't an
to me now just to be clear I
don't I don't know if this is true or
not I know that this claim is being made
I have about as much proof of that as
they do have the allegations of rape but
I can tell you beyond any shadow of a
doubt you know this Jill that people
here employees have been offered money
from these gossip rags to try and Dish
dirt on this company absolutely and they
don't care if it's true they don't care
if it's true they don't care if there's
any Contex they don't care if it's true
if it's a lie I just need you to say
something that I can use out of context
against these guys meaning some of them
the same Publications as Russell Brand
people directly either in this office or
my circle of friends they have had
someone step forward and say here is a
check can you can you give us anything
personal that is negative on Steven
Crowder or Gerald they that has happened
I can tell you that happens all the time
it's a Shakedown and there are people
that you hire to do this shaking down
when people say yeah they're going after
Trump he sure look by the way we need to
be able to separate maybe Donald Trump
has done some dickish things there still
is the Shakedown for things that he
didn't do right Russell Brand absolutely
promiscuous he was addicted to Opium we
know all of that that can be true and he
could be being shaken down for things
that he didn't do and they want to blur
those lines so that they can
specifically proactively remove one's
ability to make a living it is a war
make no mistake about that you're
already at War you may just not know it
yet Russell Brand is at War for his
reputation for his name and to provide
for his family I hope that he fully
understands that we've you've been
through it I'm telling you that's what
these people do it's a dark when people
talk about the swamp I think that the
media the media swamp the media
entertainment industry swamp is far
worse and you had a rude awakening to
for my litness test is Gerald you know
why he's the he is the biggest boy scout
I've ever known in my life and they just
made they just made up you have no
you don't have skeletons in your closet
you don't even have a
closet I'm not perfect at all but I mean
some of the stuff that does come out on
people you're just like I I have a fresh
of eyes for this stuff now I'm like I
don't believe most of that yeah I don't
believe because the media like think
about this three newspapers get together
and decide that they're going to come
out at once and not get the one thing
that they always want which is exclusive
information so that people buy their
paper their publication subscribe to
their online whatever it may be they're
not going to do that they're actually
going to collude together to put out a
story that ends up being a hitpiece on
this guy and then these companies I mean
it's it's Alex Jones 2.0 for different
reasons right these companies start
dropping him down okay well he's a
comedian he tours he does okay so let's
get rid of his shows let's get rid of
his agent let's get rid of Netflix I
think you actually had some overlays on
some of those things like some of the
things that are being taken away from
Russell bran right now right so right I
I don't know it's been Tak taken off of
BBC One yep it's it's just all acting
together exactly hold a second go back
to the BBC that that one where it says
it now uh before that one before yeah
says Russell Brand content removed from
BBC because it now Falls below public
expectations hey remember remember when
the left used to say right every time
the right would get upset like let's say
Shawn Penn would say something
and the right would say all right I'm
not going to support his films anymore
they would say you need to separate the
art from the artist by the way I think
that sometimes that is true but they
didn't say that the BBC removed his
content because he they said because now
the content and this is a Fran slip is
below their expectations same thing will
happen by the way if you're a comedian
this is what happens what happens all of
a sudden you're not fun anymore they WR
a hit piece like Dave Chappelle when he
started making jokes about the the tea
driving the LGB that was hilarious the
alphabet jokes that he was making and
people were like oh Dave Chappelle is
not funny how what how has the content
changed that was on BBC it's not changed
at all but now it falls below
expectations because of allegations that
seem to have no credibility at this
point in time that's what it is they
will look you for example with comedy
you don't have to think it's funny you
have to admit that it was a joke you
don't have to like Russell bran but you
have to admit that the content did meet
your expectations because he's talented
at what he did instead boy talk about
talk about erasing history talk about
gaslighting they want to erase this from
the existence of media of the
entertainment industry racist influence
well they exactly they want to make sure
he has no voice to defend himself yeah
thank God for places like Rumble yep
thank God for places like Rumble and mug
club and hit like if you want that
socialism is for fig shirt to make a
comeback oh I know you really
do did you I saw I saw another note
passing is it is it is it about already
okay you stop focusing on my Note well I
just know cuz there's so many notes and
I think it's like you know sometimes
sometimes you do naughty things over
there not that much of a voice I wonder
can he uh can he Sue in in in Great
Britain can he sue the media outlets for
uh slander or um I don't know it's a
difficult bar to clear because keep in
mind keep in mind Johnny Depp lost his
suit in the UK I believe it was the sun
he did and then he won in a court of law
in the United States yeah huh so I don't
know uh how strict or how loose they are
the defin yeah exactly it's Sil he
should he should be able to but you know
what happens is if you do that you have
lawyers to sit you here's what happens
look I'll give you some inside baseball
the lawyers sit down and go okay but you
know if you sue for defamation right if
you sue for Lial even though this rape
is complet if your lawyers know and they
say even though this rape is completely
false what's going to happen is they're
going to go through everyone you've ever
dated they're going to go through your
your all of your devices they're going
to go through all your personal history
going to find people in college and just
so you know um they're going to find
things to damage you worse so do you
want to do this or try and make it go
away quietly and that's one thing that
you see Donald Trump president Trump he
does not go quietly into that good night
he makes it all happen out in the open
and guess what that's what you have to
do remember Brian K when he was falsely
accused said you're going to come on the
show tomorrow you're going to do it do
not listen to the lawyer there some
great lawyers out there half asan lawyer
Bill Richman one of them right there's
some great lawyers I've worked but there
are a lot of lawyers who simply want a
high-profile client and then they want
to minimize their risk their losses they
want to pad their record with a win but
they want to do it through easy cases
through layups through settling so that
technically they've never lost and
that's not necessarily congruent with
preserving your reputation and your name
and anyone else who goes through through
this having been through it having had a
lot of friends go through this just be
very very aware of that be very mindful
of who you have in your ear your circle
of influence is incredibly important and
I do hope that Russell Brand comes
through this stronger better and you
know of course I hope he didn't I hope
he didn't
rape me too yeah I do too I obviously I
hope everyone doesn't rape yeah exactly
that's a good general rule it's kind of
yeah it's kind of one of my core but
speaking of rape let's go to the UAW and
American car
manufacturers uh nice transition
segue so they're still striking right
the UAW for those of you who don't know
it's the United Auto Workers um union
now I want to be clear about something
let's frame this when they're striking
um they're not just striking against
their employers right this isn't just a
private employer employee tussle they're
striking against you you're the reason
that GM that Ford that I guess it's uh
is it stellantis is what it's called
Chrysler that kind of merch you're the
reason that the big three I'm going to
use that term because that's how you
know them you're the reason that they're
still in business you're the in American
Airlines Delta is still in business so
that they can rape you when they charge
you for your bags for your carry-ons
right they increase the costs for every
service that used to be standard yeah
hey you funded their business you bailed
them out did you get any profits what
about for the fiser the madna vaccine I
don't care if you're big business or
small business just to be clear just be
good business and the businesses that
people hate the industries people hate
the most let's go okay obviously
American auto manufacturers are one of
them you can barely get a good American
car these days um Banks
Airlines health insurance companies the
energy sector name me any industries
that are more regulated or receive more
bailouts than those comment below name
me one maybe oh maybe medical research
but that file it 100 healthare said yeah
so before we get into this right Marley
was dead to begin with uh the big three
they received an80
billion taxpayer funded bailout less
than 15 years ago right that was in 2008
that was just GM and Chrysler right came
in
just GM and Chrysler now keep in mind
because the unions will say well this
was important it was necessary right to
help the workers well the CEOs by the
way Ford CEO got 17.9 million the GM CEO
got 14.9 million here's my rule by the
way a CEO is not the same as an owner of
a company you're a glorified manager
sometimes not everyone obviously you're
a little bit different but some of these
CEOs of these big companies right
they're interchangeable they come in and
they go okay bailout if you receive $80
billion in taxpayer guess what you get
no bonus you get none whatsoever that's
the rule it should be contingent upon
that you don't get a bailout and then
you from the taxpayers and then use it
to pay yourselves more that's crazy we
just paid you $15 million right yeah and
I got to pay whatever it is for a car
and then Chrysler of course was bailed
out in the 70s well this has been an
ongoing basis again there are all kinds
of government subsidies billions of
dollars so for example there have only
been two major bailouts but what happens
is the government either subsidizes or
provides a tax break when they try and
manipulate winners and losers in the
auto uh sector by saying oh if you have
X amount of cars each car that achieves
30 m hour whatever the arbitrary EPA
standard is will give you X number of
dollars in a tax creditor subsidy so
this stuff happen this this stuff
happens all the time to be clear when
they are
protesting they are shaking you down
they are shaking you the taxpayer down
when they're living it up on Wall Street
You' heard that song they're shutting
Detroit down shut them all down don't
identity politic this on the right oh
boy I'm country shut it all down no
bailouts how about that none for
anybody so so now the UAW fifth day
labor unions car companies they failed
to reach an agreement oh I wonder how
that ends turning now to the auto worker
strike and it's huge potential impact on
America's economy the union says the
walk out could expand this week as
negotiations continue today with the
country's three biggest auto makers and
it's affecting them in three like three
really big factors I guess GM their
pickups are in Missouri for they have
SUVs in Michigan stantis has jeeps in
Ohio well basically they're they're
striking at those three plants and
they're negotiating with all three and
striking against all three at one time
this is a little bit unique this doesn't
happen this way typically right so this
is a different strategy than they've
imploded in the past so that's why it's
such a big deal because it will just
trickle down from there well the UAW has
their hands in all of the automatic they
do but they're striking against all
three typically they pick a fight with
one right now they're going and trying
to negotiate with all three at one time
and striking against all three at
specific plants well maybe it'll improve
what's that one good GM
car
uh is there is there one I don't know I
mean I like I like GMC hold on I got it
I got it no no no it's not it that's not
it the Chevy
Vault I know you see that you know
you're getting
raped so here's what the workers are
demanding from you geez for and the
reason I say this is because these these
companies right what they're demanding
this is going to put the companies in
the red and then you'll bail them out
just to be clear again they want a 46%
pay increase wow
they want a 32-hour work week but to be
paid for 40 don't we all don't we all
they want to return to their previous
pension structure back when people
worked 50 hours a week and usually lost
the skin on their top
Knuckles they want that pension
structure and they want to give it to
all workers they want health care for
retirees even the robots are on strike
that's what's happening here with GM and
yeah I mean oh jeez Johnny Five you're
better than so here's the thing let's go
through some fast facts here and you
need to understand that this is where
this ends up if they get these things of
course you will be bailing them out hey
anyone received your check from fizer
madna no not yet not even John got a
bill you receive your you receive your
check from the 2008 Auto bailout mm I
think we're in the red on that one okay
just to be all right I understand it
okay so here's a key fact number one
okay so the demands that they're making
of course are going to be catastrophic
for the consumer yep just to be and I
get it you're saying K Factory working
class and this is the problem with some
of the populism out there the unions are
very different the unions in the midwest
they're basically glorified Mobsters
right now think about this too people
say oh the American dream is dead my
parents used to be hold on a second your
parents didn't work your grandfather
didn't come back from World War II and
work a 32h hour work week yeah no and be
unionized and play cards because they
couldn't do anything I'm not kidding one
of my buddy's dads was union worker at a
Ford plant in Ohio and said I'm going to
show up late to work aren't they going
to fire you no I'm Union they can't do
anything I'm just going to go to the
break room and play cards all day anyway
right not kidding 100% I don't need this
workingclass hero crap because then they
try you couldn't last a day in my union
ah I bet I could do a few years that's a
feisty game of space I bet I could do a
few you can nap through a few years so
the strike itself will immediately lead
to price increases according to just one
New Jersey Ford dealership uh they said
the strike if the strike continues for
Just Two Weeks prices are going to be
hiked up 20% now this happens of course
through you'll have some Panic buying
you'll have of course supply issues the
average monthly car payment by the way
is already $733 that's up 8% since just
last year that's insane 733 wow yeah
yeah wow so again it's you what you can
have is supporting this workingclass
Hero at the cost of people who can't uh
or who who aren't afforded the luxury of
working 32-hour work weeks in a union
and never ending taxpayer bailouts and
I'll compare them by the way to other
workers and factories here in the unit
let me just make this a quick point
right so they targeted these plants
because eventually the other plants end
up working working or not having enough
parts or they have too many parts to
send these plants for finishing anyway
it starts gumming up the entire works
right so now they're going to raise
prices now there's not going to be
enough new cars do you know what that's
going to do to the used car market so
UAW is basically striking new cars will
dry up the prices will Skyrocket which
means the prices of used cars the only
cars that are going to be available by
that point are going to Skyrocket as
well we just went through this this
means that the average everyday working
single parent somebody struggling to get
by whose car breaks down they need a car
to get to work can't yeah because of
your strike for 32h hour work weeks with
40 hour pay and 43 46% pay increase Oh I
thought of another industry education
there you go hey there you go you n Nar
a pel grant to be found and now of
course you talk about the the
skyrocketing cost the American dream is
going you say man I can't afford a house
well that's been bailed out of of course
the housing market big Banks I can't
afford a car well what happens when
there's a never-ending supply of
taxpayer Bots do you think that for GM
do you think they restructure and they
say okay we have to find a way to trim
cost and make it more affordable
absolutely not what do you think happens
yeah what do you think happens with
schools when they just say well we're
just going to charge it well I can't
afford that don't worry the government
will make it up hey now you have that
hyperinflation now remember by the way
adding to the cost of these cars the big
threes for example is these unbelievable
healthc care plans if Cadillac
healthcare plans if I may by the way
isn't it funny that the Cadillac you
know used to say the cat that's the
Cadillac of the Cadillac isn't even the
Cadillac of cars yeah I don't want your
Cadillac version of anything yeah refer
this is the Cadillac of mugs like you're
saying it's mediocre and
unreliable breaks
down people do that with military grade
they go oh it's military grade like yeah
exactly a bare minimum so the cost by
the way for the health care of these
workers is 150%
more than the average across the United
States and comment below if your car
payment is is crushing your monthly
budget and by the way for the first time
it's it's happening if you have a used
car your monthly payment now here's a
key fact that you also need to know fact
number two here we can hit that Stinger
if the union gets its way right the big
three they will lose they will lose
competitively to foreign Rivals and they
deserve to anyway and this comparison is
more important because you might be
saying yeah well hold on the worker is
getting screwed well no no no it's just
GM and Ford you have to understand how
much money is being pocketed by the
unions they don't represent their
workers they they're hand inand with the
CEOs so if we add up the costs and I did
this back in I believe 2010 with a film
called Detroit and ruins where I went
down to the actual uh old Packard plant
in Detroit um GM and Ford the total
labor cost per hour will go up to $150
per hour wow up from $64 an hour over
double yes much more than double with
all of the stuff that they're including
over from 64 to1 15 now compare that to
these other guys right this is a stark
comparison now nowhere else nowhere else
in any business again does someone go to
their boss and say so look I know that
I'm doing a bad job
MH I know know that what we're doing
here is I mean not even in the realm of
being competitive that's not lost on me
but let me if I may just float an idea
mhm triple pay oh no why didn't you ask
sooner yeah I've been waiting go now
hold hold on wait a second wait a second
wait oh you thought I was asking you no
no the uh the 300 million people behind
you the taxpayers oh yeah sure yeah take
their money how do you think they're so
bold and asking for this because it is
not subject to Market forces $642 $50
now let's compare that to by the way
Toyota Hyundai American workers
non-union but they're some of these cars
are more American than American cars I
think the most American car is probably
a Tesla I think they did the math it was
something like the toy someone can fact
check me the Toyota Tacoma or something
like that was the most American car as
far as not only assembly but the parts
used so Toyota Hyundai the total labor
cost per hour $55 an hour wow $55 an
hour and by the way those people make
very good livings they're just far more
efficient they don't get the same
bailouts that the big three do Tesla
total labor cost about
$45 and what's going to happen here by
the way this is going to help give
Chinese electric vehicles the ability to
break into the United States Market if
you're if you're paying attention which
brings us to fact number three if anyone
is to blame here well first off okay the
UAW yes and the autom manufacturers and
our stupid government who just keeps
bailing out filled business model yeah
okay we get all that but certainly the
man who has been suckling at the
government te for I believe it's 72
years that's chafing you have former
Vice President Biden here he is someone
who's never earned in the private sector
in his life saying that the people uh at
the big three they they need to pay more
why because nothingness auto companies
have uh seen record profits but those
record profits have not been shared
fairly in my view with those workers oh
wait hold on a second how about sharing
it with the the people who bailed them
out how do you go from hey we're
bankrupt 80 billion bailout and that's
before hyperinflation I bet you that's
like5 trillion doll today even though
we're just going back to 2008 880
billion bailout then record profits and
none of us see a dime oh it's only about
the well why is it about the unions oh
that's because 97% of their funding goes
to Democrats right they donate to
Democrats also this allows Biden a
little bit more control I hate to say
follow the money but he's demanding that
by 2030 60% of all cars on the road are
electric vehicles never mind the fact
that we don't have the infrastructure
and a lot of our electricity doesn't
come from quote unquote Renewables it's
just something that he needs to do
because he needs to grease some Palms
before the next election and according
to a statement from stantis that's again
Chrysler Dodge Jeep that's what the
that's the new parent company um the
company needs to cut workers pensions
and health care costs to meet Federal
government's requirements that 60% of
all new passenger vehicles be sold uh
that be that are sold that be sold that
be sold that's the Chrysler 200 300 300
yeah it's like the poor man's bent that
be
sold you don't think e be EVS be like
they is but they do uh
60% so they're going to have to cut
pensions because 60% of all new
passenger vehicles sold in the country
have to be electric by 2030 they've said
that so what do you have you have a
government that says hey you have to do
this why because John carry ALG Gore
global warming you have to do this by
2030 company says well I can't afford
that they say well don't worry we'll
Force the taxpayer to bail you out and
then you'll be able to do what we want
Even though uh most American consumers
don't want those
Vehicles that's where we are Biden of
course voted for the 2008 bailout he
bragged about it saying part of that was
uh sorry part of that was B in out the
automobile industry talking about I
believe tarp and the overall bailout
packages saving thousands of jobs tens
of thousands of jobs over time I've
never understood this I know why is it
virtuous to save a job here by robbing
someone else especially when that job is
two three times the hourly labor cost of
the person who's bailing them out can
someone explain to me why why for some
reason that scene is generous and not
thievery I don't know but I I really
hope so president Donald Trump has a
really good opportunity to go up and
actually speak some truth to the UAW
he's doing a prime time address I
believe to the UAW on next Wednesday
when we're doing the live stream for the
debate right so he has an
[Music]
opportunity has an opportunity to go up
and do that but I don't know I don't
know what to expect yeah we'll see maybe
he's the guy though he's the guy you
want talking to these people how many uh
salaries is this guy negotiated how many
deals is this true but I hope he goes up
and does that it kind of feels like
that's the guy like like you said
Biden's never been in the private sector
he never negotiated a deal like that I
mean maybe with Ukraine but he's never
that's just more of a
giveaway well just gives them cash it's
like being in that glass he might Pander
a little bit tube with a money fan he
might Pander a little bit but I think
any pandering he does is in an effort to
make a good deal in his mind I hope that
that is the case we'll see yeah I just
hope he goes on he's like look you want
$150 an hour that's not going to happen
all right one time I Uber blacked in a
Chevy
Vault the suspension was it was excuse
me it was difficult it was like being
raped it was like being raped in a Chevy
Vault what kind of seat were you in
Chevy
Vault and by the way here's something as
well I need to put a moratorium in by
the way I say it too much to be clear
the strike is not about the workers it's
about your bailout funds but the the
union leadership we talk about the uh
the uh the equity and diversity right
scores we talk about all of these the
ESG all of these things right we often
look over what happens right here in the
United States with these long-standing
unions so let me read you from the UAW
constitution the uaw's Constitution
enshrines our Union's long-standing
values and agreed vision of a society
that Embraces and implements economic
and social justice for all people what a
second you make
cars they have a constitution yeah they
have amendments exactly by McKenzie they
don't have a Bill of Rights but they
have a bill of sale definitely yeah
their amendments are just recalls can we
have an Insurrection against them yes
let's storm Detroit and what's their
vision of society well the UAW pack by
the way huge you want to look at big
money and politics look at unions okay
UAW they're pack over 97% to Democrats
Jes 97% to Democrats W $50 million yeah
that's a lot so and by the way if you're
in the union you have to be in the union
and you have no say in the matter and
they take your money and they give it to
you think that 97% of people in Michigan
or Ohio at these plants you think 97% of
them voted for Joe Biden of course not
so that's basically coercion and the
point that we're making here is when you
look at this just remember where this
goes it's it's the same thing as the
vaccine sorry the MRNA injection think
about all of the industries that you
despise the most Airlines Banks
Healthcare or really you can just
consider any industry any sector of the
economy that is experienced
hyperinflation air travel Banks health
health insurance uh and of course
lending yep and of course well that
would fall under Banks but of course uh
also education right that is true those
costs of
skyrocketed do you see a consistent
through line here all of them all of
them are beholden to the government te
and the thing is that only exists
because they rob you and so this is
where we need to make sure we don't
identity politi it on the right like
they do on the left with just they do it
by orientation gender uh sometimes we
try and say well look working out there
working class well if you run a business
you're also working class if if if you
went to school and you work with your
mind are you also not working class is
is the only group of people that
classifies as working class the people
on the factory lines of American auto
manufacturers who want $150 plus dollar
an hour in total cost for 32 hours a
week but paid like they work
40 that's your definition of American
working class and the American dream no
this is about buying votes you don't
need to get to Soros and Epstein Island
those those things are true hey by the
way what we're talking about Russell
Brand and his potential sexual myses I
don't know if you know this but there's
a very small island really where in the
West Indies it's not but sounds good
it's called sex Island some refer to it
as pedophile Island perhaps look over
there for the sexual
indiscretions we still don't have that
Client List yeah no no nothing now we
look at the vaccine as well $18 billion
right with warps spe taxpayer funding
record profits Now where's your check
where's your check from GM where's your
check from Ford this is where I want to
see the uprising this is where I want to
see people pissed off when people talk
about you know rich men north of Rich
that's great but hey let's be clear
about this all of these people are
screwing you just because someone works
with their hands in a factory line if
they're if they if their job only exists
because of your never- ending taxpayer
guess what they should be out of a job
and I don't care well hold on a second
that means they get nothing I can pay a
little more in taxes no what's the
number 50% if you're in California it's
50% no you shouldn't have to pay any
more in taxes to support a job that
doesn't exist that is not the purpose of
the government and certainly not for
Biden who doesn't know jack about
anything that's ever taken place in the
private sector to tell these businesses
you know what I think you should pay
more where are you getting that from
what's your frame of reference your only
frame of reference is voting yes on
taking everyone's money here to give it
to those hacks and it's a Shakedown it's
a Shakedown of Russell Brand and it's a
Shakedown of the American taxpayer it's
a Shakedown of you the American worker
who deserves to save scrape earn have an
opportunity to pursue the American dream
but no we've decided that we are going
to do away with equal opportunity to
ensure equity and the people ensuring
Equity who give $50 million UAW social
yeah those are the people
and then that's reciprocated by people
in government that's the swamp to be
clear people often say swamp but they
don't Define it shirs politicians shirts
unelected officials like fouchy it's
also the media it's also the
entertainment industry and it's also
unions who decide to rape you of your
pop pocketbook in order to support
losers that doesn't mean everyone
working on the factory line but the UAW
serves to protect losers just like the
teachers unions serve to protect Bad
Teachers who who get put in rubber rooms
if they're shitty at their job how about
unemployment I really don't know I kind
of know what they're thinking but I
don't exactly know what the American
Auto Workers are think I'm not a psychic
but it's a good thing we have a psychic
here in the
[Music]
office
[Applause]
[Music]
we're not in a union shop it's the best
we can do all right uh coming out do we
have them here on the line can you pop
them there so I
so last week uh this journalist I don't
even know if I guess we're not allowed
to say the the word but that's why we'll
do most of this interview on mug Club
but Owen Shroyer madmax world.tv well we
can say that sentenced to 60 days in
jail for his alleged role in January 6th
by the way hit the like button right now
if you're on YouTube uh if you just if
you understand that this is a political
Witch Hunt now I just want to be clear
by the way uh they've been pretty damn
clear the judge said I don't think you
were trying to distract the crowd or
move move the crowd away from the
capital that's his crime was he wasn't
stopping them judge is like I don't look
I don't think you did anything but you
certainly weren't stopping all of the
people there well he also wasn't shoving
anyone off a balcony they going to
charge the capital police as well yeah
they're going to charge the capital
police no no no remember they are the
law and so I think we have him now on
the line let's welcome our guest Owen
[Music]
Shroyer Mr Shroyer are you there can you
see me hear me sir great to be here
Stephen okay hold on we're just going to
adjust your volume a little bit it's
coming in a little hot but I'm glad to
have you and by hey not to blow smoke up
your ass but I said uh this to obviously
your colleague there um Alex when uh the
Alex Jones trial was going on and you
took the stand I thought you did about
as good of a job as I've ever seen
someone in that kind of a position you
did not allow them to Corner you and I
tell you I was Alex is always
entertaining but I very much appreciated
uh you swinging the bat and and doing it
like you
did well thanks I know that uh for a man
in Alex's position it takes a lot to
trust the people around him and I
believe I've earned that trust and I
think for him to be comfortable with me
in that hot seat at that time was a part
of that trust and so I'm glad that let's
just say they they couldn't Corner me
they couldn't beat me down and they
couldn't use me against Alex like they
intended to right and that's what we're
talking about here with Russell bran
today like this is what they try and do
they try and divide you in your own uh
amongst your own ranks and let's go here
to kind of they're trying to do this
with January 6 right they're hoping that
enough people out there say oh no no no
I'm not of those people when there are
hundreds of thousands of people there
January 6th who didn't didn't so much as
uh as litter so let me just brief people
here who aren't and you can correct me
if I have any of this wrong um this by
the way 60 days jail for your ledge
rooll January what they say meaning you
were there the US District Judge um I
guess it's judge Kelly says that you
helped quote unquote amp up the crowd
and you did plead guilty to just
breaching restricted Capital grounds um
do I have that about right is that where
we are
now yeah obviously there are a lot more
complex details than that but those are
both accurate facts so what did can I
ask you this what are they saying you
did
wrong you know Stephen it's uh it's a
very unique case in fact there might not
be any other case like it because when
we get the transcription uh fully
released and published and when people
read the sentencing memo which is is
public right now I did a whole hourlong
press conference on it with my lawyer
the government is trying to have their
cake and eat it too and I think it's
worth mentioning before I even go into
what they are saying I did there's a lot
of political pressure in DC and I think
when you're dealing with us attorneys
and the federal government whether it's
this case or any case they always want a
100% conviction rate and they always get
it this is part of the corrupt plea deal
process which we can get into my case
with that in a second but here's
virtually what the government argued is
that I didn't have to go into the
building I didn't have to commit any
violent crimes I didn't have to talk to
a police officer or touch a police
officer but because of what I said
before and after January 6th those are
what they argued in front of the judge
is proof of my crime and my intent from
that day now now here's why it's Unique
for multiple reasons
a since when does the government
criminalize speech because that is
exactly what they've done here in the
sentencing memo there are four
subsections each subsection deals
exactly with what I said not what I did
they make that very clear I didn't do
anything that day but what I said is
what is being criminalized so they're
obviously listening to my show every day
I guess I was a little tickled by that
they proved that in their sentencing
memo but we've never seen this before
criminalizing speech but what's odd is
this is also in the sentencing memo they
quote two interesting things they say in
the memo that I was there with my team
to deescalate that's a quote from our
team on the ground
deescalate not to mention the quotes of
Alex Jones saying don't go in don't go
in go around we're not going in we got a
booth set up over here they do tend to
leave that out of course but they also
quote saying we're here to peacefully
we're here to peacefully share our voice
can I ask you a question because they're
charges are different with different
people right and sometimes it's hard
where people kind of throw everything
January 6th in the same uh pot and we
just saw that with the Qin on Shaman
who's really just guilty of dressing up
like a sports fan let's be honest here a
lot of the people there were invited in
it's the people's house right it's the
capital so that's on camera that a lot
of them were invited in um and even
those people were charged with
trespassing are they trying to claim
that you're not one of the people who
was personally invited in that they were
only es escorting individuals because
that's on camera ad nauseum all right
you can come in single file what's what
do they say to
that I don't even really think that's a
question worth answering Stephen not not
to offend you but because I think the
case here is that they have to take an
example of me right this isn't about
what happened that day that's clear this
isn't about Trump's uh speaking event
this isn't about how they open the
Capital Door somebody opened the
maglocks people removed the people waved
them in this isn't about that so I mean
we could pontificate on that and that is
perfectly relevant to the overall story
but when it comes to my story that's not
what this is about this is about
somebody in the government somebody in
the Justice Department somebody in the
Democrat Party wants my pound of Flesh
that's what this is all about that's
where this comes from that's why they
have to lock my ass in jail well the
reason I bring it up it's just because
of the term breaching I guess I've
breached every house party to which I
was invited you know this is this is the
problem is they they confus use the
language right and they just go ah you
know what uh let's make an example of
this person here I want to and I know
that obviously you guys are broadcasting
man maxw world.tv we're going to
continue this uh on mug Club here or on
Rumble if you're watching on Rumble
because some of these things we can't
say on YouTube but everyone on YouTube
you know what madmax world.tv right ow
andare you guys know you guys can go and
oh Gerald you about to say something
yeah really quickly I just wanted to
make sure so put the put the lower third
back up for him so the way to support
Owen I want to make sure we plug that
before we go uh to mug Club sorry it is
give send go
/de ens sorry I was plugging it was up
there before but I just want to make
sure we give for people listening on
audio is giv send go.com defend Owen I'm
assuming that's your your legal defense
fund right Owen I'm sorry I was I was in
the moment no stay in the moment that's
what's so great about you or you can go
to defend owen.com if you just want the
short URL defend owen.com and just so
people know we're appealing this and we
believe that this case may end up at the
Supreme Court and that's might just be
where it belongs yeah I I absolutely
hope you do and yeah defend o.com is
certainly a better URL much shorter so
much much defend defend o.com uh if
you're watching on Rumble click the
button below you get to continue
watching on M Club YouTube I get to say
it again today yeah there we go thank
you Rumble YouTube piss off we'll
continue with
one
[Applause]
yeah